uh get my mans David jaffy in on this
one and yeah we want to talk Connie Boo
and um obviously potential PlayStation
Studios um changing some say turmoil
there's a lot obviously you know uh this
was per access but they gave proper
credit to Lord David jaffy on the
sourcing and uh Kylie Bo who started at
PlayStation in 97 before the platform
launch she started in in uh 87 8 wow
take it back not PlayStation but at Sony
or 89 I think 89 salute salute that's OG
talk so yeah head of internal game
production no longer at the company as
first noted by uh David jaffy and um
yeah somebody the Hall of Fame
credentials include production oversight
of PlayStation Classics ranging from
siphon filter ratting Clank to The Last
of Us Mar Spider-Man says booth has not
commented and Sony has not clarified the
reason for her exit in a statement by
axios the PlayStation refs said Booth
help Drive the success PlayStation
Studios is experiencing today and her
passion and fostering an environment
where A team's Creative Vision could
fully flourish has left a positive
impact on many game developers we're
thankful for Connie's numerous
contributions to the company and wish
her the best in future endeavors also
the article goes on to talk about other
internal things with Sony media m m
molecule Studio making of little uh big
planet and dreams says it's laying off
some workers following significant
strategic changes so um yeah obviously
Jaffrey you know you had a lot of this
on on your YouTube channel you broke
this first um there was some specific
points that you made I want to kind of
list and then ask you kind of like in
question format if you're cool um so all
right the f one of the first things was
like Connie Booth was not let go she not
retired she was fired so Lord jaffy why
is her firing opposed to like a layoff
or resignation significant and then
educate me who doesn't know why she's so
revered why you know so many people like
yourself internally speak up for her in
production like what's the history here
well again so I mean she hasn't said
anything so there's you know all I can
tell you is I have like four people
telling me what happened two are at Sony
and two are out of Sony and they're all
like no she was fired um so the
significance of
it there's two things that are very
significant the first thing is if you
look at uh who she is and what she has
done I mean the Academy of interactive
Arts and Sciences two years ago put her
in the Hall of Fame this is not a woman
who's out to pasture and they're like
hey thanks for all the fish goodbye this
is a woman who literally less than a
month ago you know her crew put out
Spider-Man 2 which is kind of the only
[__] freaking game that uh you know
that Sony had I mean MLB of course
Workhorse of Sony's MLB but you know
that that's not like she's over she's
still totally plugged in doing what she
does her guys plugged in doing what they
do um so part of it is like okay it's
significant because this is somebody
who's making you guys a lot of money and
her leadership has been very valuable
over decades um she's not ready to be
done it's not you know what I'm saying
it's not like okay your last four games
you're just out of the Zeitgeist now not
a big deal we love you but you know how
business works right that's not what was
happening um and the other reason it's
significant is it shines a light
on
um the fact that because Sony I think uh
on col show he was talking about this
you know in in given the the vacuum that
we are in when it comes to information
from Sony we're all left just to
speculate and make crap up and no one
really knows but it it's one of those
it's it's one more pretty significant
brick especially after Jim Ryan retiring
and or maybe being pushed out I don't
know um that says okay what is happening
over there the factions thing the
the thing um and I don't think it's you
know I I look at it um and I have some
information that I you know I actually
reached out to to tillow at axus and I
said I said this guy reached out to me
he's at Sony he knows all kinds of stuff
he he laid it all be he told me about
Jim Ryan and what he thinks Jim Ryan and
what happened with Connie and you know
but I said it's one guy I said yeah he's
at Sony and he's he's a longtime Sony
guy but I don't he's like yeah you
shouldn't you know unless you got
don't don't get into that but the the
point though is I think if people are
out there going Connie and then Jim Ryan
and then factions right uh and how much
control Bungie having and totillo or sh
L Jas shri's earlier reporting uh about
um the studios being unhappy with games
as a service at least some of them I I I
think it's a valid and the information
source I'm talking about tracks with
this it's a valid thing to
go that that uh Foundation right now is
being shaken up and and and where they
come out the other side or what that
looks like um and whose vision is
running the day in terms of do we stay
with games as a service as at the level
we thought we were do we pivot a little
bit back you know that is why it's
significant because it's just one more
really big reason to go yeah they're
they're struggling to kind of sail into
the next uh uh sort of epoch of the
games industry which they have dominated
for so long so I don't think it's a bad
thing I think in a lot of ways Xbox is
going through I was talking to somebody
earlier it's like
Xbox um I'm a big Phil Spencer fan I'm a
big game pass fan um but I've always
been very critical of their production
management when it comes to first party
and I'm still I'm still like Matt booty
was promoted I'm sorry what um but but
but and I don't know the guy may you
know but whatever but it's not the point
the point is though is that they you
know it takes time to learn even though
these are trillion in one case uh dollar
companies it takes time to learn how to
do this and it seems like Xbox has
struggled for a while and they're still
struggling but they're getting better I
think to learn how to become the of
management Studio that Sony was I think
Sony now is put into this position where
as Shawn Laden predicted five years ago
four years ago the things that they've
kind of made their uh Brilliance in
which is the single player cinematic all
that stuff y that's just one it it's
becoming harder and harder to justify
those budgets because the profits aren't
as much because you know and there's not
new Gamers coming in and so they're
having to go okay well how do we
still you know rule this industry mhm
and and take what we're great at but we
have to Pivot somewhere things are
changing so it it really is a uh it's a
fascinating and uh just you know very
interesting to me uh uh perspective to
stand back and watch all this from a
30,000 foot View and go you know where
these guys going to come out the other
end are they going to be able to figure
out how to sustain these big Games come
out other pause
King pause on King continue continue J
you being messy
continue um so yeah I mean I I I think
it it it's quite interesting to me and
you know it does remind me speaking of
aus ghost but I saw a speak at GDC a
couple years back or 10 years back now
and he was talking about how in trouble
Nintendo was when they I think it was
like out of the GameCube era right
before the 3DS or the DS or whatever it
was and you know he he gave this now
very tropy but at the time none of us
had heard it uh analogy he said you know
uh Coke and Pepsi used to battle like
crazy and it was one then it was Pepsi
then it was coke you know and then
suddenly something happened and Koke
just took over and Pepsi couldn't get a
break and so instead of continuing to
try to beat Coke um and swim in those
bloody red Waters he says they they
absolutely you know reinvent themselves
and they started bottling water and they
became now now Coke is taken over that
too but at the time though you know
their bottled water that changed
everything for them and and but it's
like but you're Pepsi you don't make
water it's like well we do
now you got reinvent yourself I think
when you hear him aana talking about how
they had to do that at Nintendo and go
okay we're not going to be able to
compete uh with the Sony's and and and
whatever I don't I guess Microsoft was
out at the time Microsoft's the world
on Fidelity on production value what are
we good at okay let's do the 3DS and the
DS and let's do the Wii and suddenly
everything changed for these guys so I I
think there's nothing to not you know
it's a company it doesn't have shame but
there's there's nothing to feel bad
about I mean this is how business gets
done this is how create you know I hope
there's a Visionary at Sony right now
maybe it's Scott Roy maybe it's a new
person we've never heard of maybe it's
Herman Hol I don't I don't know maybe
it's Duckman who knows who is is going I
I got this I have this I see what this
can be um because I think they need that
but I think every company needs that you
know Apple used to have it he was an
[__] but you know jobs knew what he
knew and now they're just kind of awful
but anyway I want to I want to follow up
because the the the pivot part is the
part I really say confused about but I
personally this is this is my take I
understand based on what you say like we
know Sony PlayStation I call them the
hash just one the Tria the Cinematic
narrative based Focus game high
graphical Fidelity that bit right and
you made a fantastic Point as far as the
revenue right and those maybe not being
able to generate what they're looking
for in this climate with games and
service so in my opinion games of
service is the correct pivot on some
level right the question is twofold one
if Jim Ryan's message was this right
internally from what you know you kind
had said and then he either retires or
pushed out whatever it is right and my
thing is if that was the first question
is if that was Jim Ryan's Vision why is
Connie getting blamed for it in a sense
right and then the second part is you
know I tell me how you feel about this
story I have in reference to Bungie
being there overlooking the the the the
games of service right CU I look at it
as okay we have a new adopted child in
the house and he go by his own ru he
don't have to go to bed at 10:00 he
don't have he listens to his whole thing
and he gets to tell the other kids what
to do when it comes to their projects
right so for me I all even though Bungie
I love them I a destiny fan I'm a Halo
guy I think they make nothing but the
greatest you know Shooters as far as
feeling Shooters but I can understand
resentment in the building if they're
telling and cancelling project so again
the first thing games of service why
does it follow fallani two Bungie
potentially being problematic in the in
the in the family so to speak so on the
Connie thing I mean that's I I have one
person's answer that's the guy I can't
really get into but I asked him that I
said this doesn't make any sense the the
thing to to know I think is that when
people say it fell on Connie I don't
what we don't know is does that mean
that um oh no you know The Last of Us
faction I mean literally look at it this
way The Last of Us factions hired the
the guy who figured out how to monetize
fortnite and not make a game that was
pay for power and it became the biggest
free to- playay game certainly from
America ever phenomenal um that guy left
right that guy left which means okay
whatever their plan was his plan was
clearly Bungie wasn't interested um and
so what we don't know is was it Jim Ryan
you know getting cozy cozy with Bungie
and saying you know now you
just that's what the bunge people say
you know and and maybe Connie was there
going look I've man I've managed at some
level I mean Naughty Dogs doesn't really
need that oversight anymore but she's
been with them since crash right yeah um
it's like these guys are upset they're
pissed you got to you know I'm not
saying that happened but I'm saying that
it could it could mean when we say that
she was fired over that is she just
bashed heads with Jim Ryan going look
these guys are your bre and butter
you're going to literally tell Neil
Duckman who's probably about to get an
Emy nomination for Last of Us um that
that you know and by the way I don't
think Jim or Bungie would be wrong I
mean it's just like Xbox right now there
are things that you don't know what you
don't know right and if Bungie came in
and gave a valid criticism of their of
their stickiness of their game
stickiness was the word then you know I
mean one would like to think naughty dog
would say oh I hate that you're right
but you're right yep yep let us let us
go back we'll get back and that may be
what's happening right so it could be
that though that Connie push back on Jim
because there was this kind of turmoil
it also could be that um you know
everybody agreed when Jim Ryan started
to Pivot um to the games of the service
it's like oh that sucks but at least he
said there's a lot of money still being
spent on the single player stuff and uh
but everybody was like yeah they need
this this is where a lot you know if you
can get one or two of these big hits
what the hell K is ready to burst
clearly I just got a question I got a
question yeah that that part was really
crazy but U is Rome
burning here we go because I my my
thought process has always been Sony
won't be taken down from outside
interference
they will Ex implode from inside and
I've always felt that great Nations and
great kingdoms has always done it to the
themselves so yeah no I don't I don't
think it's that dramatic I don't because
I think Sony is out of necessity
responding to the changes in the market
and the frankly the generational changes
I mean kids today they're you know I'm
not saying they don't play console games
but they're playing they're on Discord
playing Discord games with their friends
and they're playing Roblox they're
playing fortnite you know they have a
very different perspective of what it
means to game um You Know Than People
Our Generation My Generation whatever
right and so I think Sony is right to go
okay we we got to get our hands around
this and and and make it work for us
without hurting all of our other stuff
that people love us for and and so I
don't think I don't remember anybody
when Jim Ryan came out and announced
this that were like oh you're an idiot I
think everybody was like yeah yeah yeah
and what has happened in that time since
though is we have just seen a just Blood
Red Sea of really good games that have
come out that were games of service that
are no longer active yes and so I think
there was an assumption that not that
it's easy nothing's ever easy in video
games but it's like okay we can do this
and they probably can but I think maybe
that kind of the worm turn a little bit
on people's going [__] man we had to you
know put factions on ice and or cancel
it depending on who you ask um you know
we premiered Jade Raymond's game at the
Showcase and even though the game wasn't
shown nobody was like eh nobody really
cared uh hyenas just got cancelled
before it came out right um you know
apparently that game that's out the
finals this weekend in beta most people
like yeah it's cool but I'm not going to
play it for more than you know a day or
two and they they've already moved on
from a beta the the what was the game
that Square Enix just put out on beta
the oh was was it foam Stars foam Stars
I mean I heard a lot of people saying
that was great at Jeff Keeley show and I
was excited for it you know I'm 52 so
I'm not their target audience but I
couldn't play it more than you know
around and I'm like yeah this is not for
me so it didn't no one's talking about
that like oh I can't wait for foam stars
to come back I'm not hearing any of that
um but what I am hearing though on the
the flip side is you know Ubisoft just
released a bunch of their uh uh
quarterly reports and you know uh Mirage
did well which surprised me the crew to
or motorfest which is awesome right uh
did uh did well but they said their
biggest money maker or their biggest
Financial surprise was Rainbow Six Siege
is still delivering yeah it's a beast
for those guys right Beast right so I I
don't think it's right to say going
games is a service for Sony is stupid I
think it's dumb I think it's you know
MLB makes the money as a semi games
service right first party Studio but
what we don't know with Connie is was
she protecting the team was she
protecting the vision and Jim wanted to
Pivot there's also by the
way there's a very let's just say this
without giving away any of the details
there is a narrative that I've that's
been shared with me that it's not even
that it's not even
that logical okay that some of the
people in the narrative whether you're
talking Jim or Connie or Sean Laden or
Herman Holz I'm not going to get into
the specifics but let's just say the
narrative there's an area that exists
that say some of those people
aren't or are pretty [__] Petty um
and there may be a narrative
regarding you know I'm gonna burn some
stuff down before I go I didn't say that
okay well listen okay you know what okay
so you didn't say but I did right so the
thing is because it doesn't make any
sense and I'm not saying that's true I'm
saying yeah no I heard some something
similar right the thing is Jim is gone
in next school period at the end like
like I predicted anyway um but her
leaving now like getting fired now if
there's a conflict of in interest
between the two or teams
whatever and he's a foregone conclusion
it just seems uh like
Petty let me remove this and not only
that K not to interrupt you aren't we
hearing the team in her team in
conjunction with her I don't know if the
team walked out this was the thing
that's the key distin we're all
speculating but yeah from what I heard
and and and you you know way more than
me what I heard was I thought it was a
walk out right so I didn't hear the rest
of the information and then I got the
some of the rest of the information and
I'm pretty probably getting the second
hand from you um not that is is indirect
the individuals that's sharing the
information um that it was a walk out
but I didn't know if it was her but then
I'm hearing that she got fired so I
don't know if the team walked out after
she got fired she doesn't have a
development team as far as I know but
she had like producers right I don't
know if Brady hunt was still with her
who's been long time Insomniac third
part first party producer with Insomniac
much loved fella you know probably on
track get a nominee or ushered into
Academy active AR Sciences you know all
that I mean you know her team was
awesome when you talk about what
Microsoft doesn't have in production
management right um for first and second
party her whole team was awesome now I
did ask that and and what they said was
um there's a few people left and we know
uh what's her name Angie smithz or
smithz from right it sounds like that
and then I guess they're going to split
some of her I saw somebody saying that
like roie was going to take over some of
her teams or some of her external like
maybe he would oversee Insomniac and
somebody else would oversee this um but
the point being though is is her team I
did hear that uh a number of them were
also out when she was out now whether
they were fired or they walked because
they were protesting I have no
idea see and again you know I give it
back to you K I interrupted you no no no
no it's it's fine because he he answered
the question I just felt that it was it
was just weird in the sense that this
individual is definitely gone like he's
definitely put out information that I'm
out of here I'm retiring regardless to
what if he was fired or whatever and he
had to sign the paperwork saying you
know I'm out
of but why is she tied to this rock that
that's what that's my thing King CU my
thing is it all again regardless if it
was a walk out or they all fired to me
that represents culture right that
represents obviously she's revered she
she gets things done like the vibe I'm
getting Jaffrey is like this is the
finisher this is the person not only who
spawns great ideas and some of their
greatest franchises but also gets things
across the Finish Line I guess from a
production she she is a in the best way
possible a
beast you do not want her as an enemy
let's put it that way she plays the game
well she plays the game so the closest
equivalent I could say on the Xbox side
back in the day was be like Ferguson
right he was red for like yo he gets it
done we had Cliffy be on he was like
look no one I will never say nothing bad
about that man man that man got things
done and got I wish he would go back to
Microsoft I I I mean he is kind of a now
yeah I'm with I wish they would go to
him and say dude you need to run
development I'm with you I'm with you he
I said regardless of whatever happens to
ABK I hope they retain him and he I'm
I'm totally with you there but back on
point with this so it's like I guess
when I hear you talk and I watch your
video and first of all credit to you
because you you you got a lot of arrows
thrown your way a lot of people was
hating and saying oh but do and glooming
and it's not that bad and you know
Jaffrey sources and then you get
Vindicated but the key thing that she
said to me that resonated was like you
said look this is a sad day you know at
PlayStation based on the history and
based on what she's done and based on
the team so again to what king is
talking about if this is the case and
she's like the soul in a sense like this
before PlayStation started right so if
that's the case it's like again we don't
know if she was in conjunction with Jack
with uh Ryan's Vision or not but it to
for her to take the fall for this seems
strange it it just it just feels it
doesn't feel right but we just don't
that we just don't have like there's
there's scenarios like it could have
been you know it was uh and this is not
like Connie but you know like I said the
woman's been around she's done the stuff
and maybe she's just like okay enough
you know maybe she just went to Jim Ryan
and said you know you're an idiot you I
don't I don't know how insubordinate
was if it was at all but it could have
been literally a case for firing because
he was just disrespecting all these
people that had basically without them
he would have no job right or she could
have agreed and they both got thrown
under the bus together if he indeed got
thrown or it ALS I mean you know I know
and I'm sure you guys have heard too
that Sony is doing a lot of serious belt
tightening right now yes yeah all their
Studios and it could have been as simple
but they would never say this as going
you just put Spider-man out
uh you're in line to get a huge bonus
when when the monies come in and your
salary you know is probably you know
deep deep into the the six figures um we
probably can't afford an executive like
you especially now that Naughty Dog
pretty much runs itself Insomniac pretty
much runs it I mean I'm not taking away
from what Grady does you know but I'm
saying that it's not like it was maybe
in the past and this is me making stuff
up I'm saying we all specula we spe lot
of places you could go with why they
said goodbye but what I do hear though
is there's some pettiness at play and
what I can say because people have said
it before and it's been discussed before
and so I'm not giving away anything I
wouldn't want to do that is you know
there's been a lot of speculation about
how Shawn Laden got yeah and you know
and and and the more I hear the more
that you know at first I heard about
Alan Becker and I got it direct that
he's like yeah I heard that they they
called like on I don't know what day it
was a Tuesday and said your last day is
Friday wow and that was it that was it
this is the guy who was the first
employee facts um and had done you would
have no Twisted medal no God of War
probably I don't know you know there's a
lot of games he ushered in uh he was
there when bloodborne in Japan you know
I'm not I'm not saying he wasn't ready
to go but the that was the first thing
like Jesus that's not just good
Cutthroat business like you know you got
to be C that's mean yeah that's a squat
you out the
building no that was that was that was
that was Allan oh was Allan okay sorry
sorry yeah I'm getting confused
apparently this is becoming more clear
by a number of people and not like I
said I'm not given this one source um
that it was really offensive I mean it
it was like you're you know they did him
very very dirty getting him out of there
and so you know but it's like how can
you treat s you going jump like I just I
struggle with Legends being treated this
way and may again I'm outside looking I
don't burning I get it but s like do you
guys see what I'm saying see though like
isn't that just wild disrespect but it's
not just the disrespect it's the it's
you're right but it's the it's the it's
the ability to maneuver politically well
enough that you can convince the powers
that be to give you a position that
clearly someone
else has proven oh we play know and what
they know how to
do Laden I think was a much better
executive than Jim Ryan in my opinion I
don't know I can't have the numbers but
and people say well look what Jim Ryan
did with PS5 I'm like yeah but that's
built off built off the old but we got
we got to give him we got to give him
Europe though I got to defend Jim on
Europe with their growth there but I
feel what you're saying at all I'm just
saying that that Sean it wasn't like was
like eh of course oh that's a yeah yeah
I mean he he still had and still has a
lot to offer and so the idea in my
opinion that he was sort of the more I
hear the more I hear he was treated so
just like yeah wow it's t it's trash
Tuesday so you're trash you're out um
I'm just like are you out of your mind
you know this you know so let's just say
this if there's a pettiness going on
um you know I'm glad that it may not be
going on for too much longer um yeah so
I need to jump in and I got I got
something for king after this I watch
your thoughts on this I got you I want
need your thoughts on all this um I I
just think at the end of the day
everything is money everything is money
and when you talk about the disrespect
to these Legends um we've seen it before
you know Konami gets fed up with coima
we don't really care what you've done we
don't care what you've done for us like
it's you're gone and when you know the
powers that be are more focused on a
different direction and you clash with
that direction in any way shape or form
it do feel like you're going to be on
board with it or you're going to use
whatever you know whatever Clouts you
have internally at that point to try to
set up roadblocks to that stuff
happening they're gonna get you out of
there and if it has to be and and I and
I think in a lot of ways you know maybe
they gave her maybe they gave her the
opportunity to walk out and say hey walk
away and do it on your terms and
everything's going to be nice and
beautiful or if you refuse and you want
to die on that Hill cool we appreciate
that we're going to walk you out of the
building and that's just the way it is
and it and it and that's just business
when when cash ruls everything it
doesn't matter what you've done for them
it's what it matters what you've done
lately for them I I'm sorry please
finish please finish and the and we as
fans may see that as a disrespect
because of what they've done to that
point to that company they're an
employee and and again they're more than
willing to give them their flowers if
they go out on the terms that they
dictate for them if they don't want to
do that they're G to walk you out like a
criminal or whatever and going to make
sure and that's just the nature of it so
for me go ahead sorry I mean just
speculating again speculating completely
as to what might have happened it really
does feel like you know to jaffrey's
point she was not on board with what was
happening at least to the extent to
which it was happening right it's one
thing to say hey we need to start
dipping our toes into this in order to
also another thing to tell every first
party Studio you better make onea to
make these guys I didn't say that happen
I know you didn't say I don't know if
that's what happened but that's another
thing that we that we're sort of we're
assuming might have happened is that
this this you're telling the teams that
are known for doing a certain thing
extremely well at the top at the top of
the game in the industry you're telling
them to Pivot to something else because
we have to make this you know x amount
of money and then at the same time he
also did the right thing by bringing in
teams and bringing in people that know
how to do that and and working on that
as well so it at it seems like at some
point that pivot went extremely in One
Direction meaning more of like hey
everything's going to have some sort of
a game of service sort of uh uh
application to it and everything that we
put out H is going to be somewhat in
this realm whether we still put out our
you know our single player you know 15
hour narrative games um there's going to
be some component to it and maybe that's
something that she wasn't on board with
if you look at her history she's only
really worked on single player stuff
right because that that's been their DNA
she did so calm she did so she did that
okay so she did okay so I'll take that
back so she was part of that now going
back to that SoCal mag those are maybe
mag is is a bigger thing but those are
very it's different when it's a
multiplayer game service gam service
there's a difference yeah right and and
I think we've talked about this the fact
that the pivot was correct we've always
felt it was a little late to the party
right and when you're late to the part
and you've already seen so many other
great games just fall to the Wayside
simply because people don't have the
bandwidth for
them you're you're thinking that we're
going to drop 10 or 15 of these the hope
that one or two of them hits and allows
us to continue to make money and over
fist off of them in a world where you
know people's bandwidth is going to a
fortnite a war zone or it's going to a
uh Whatchamacallit a a Siege or
something like that you have to now
create another Niche for that thing
within your and again an ecosystem that
you have not clarified that you were
going to expand upon so now you're
creating a niche within a niche within a
closed within a Walled Garden not saying
that you're going to go to the PC right
so if if that isn't something cuz to me
if you're doing that that's something
right so if that is the case and you're
saying oh we're going to do this within
this closed PlayStation ecosystem and
I'm Connie Booth I'm like okay now the
choices that you're making whether I
agree with them or not you're not even
making sound business decisions around
around it right and expanding the people
that we that we reach with these games
doesn't make a whole lot of sense that
again speculation I just kind of feel
like they were butting heads completely
on ideologies and it was time to go and
again it just kind of feels like her
thinking is we can do multiplayer right
we can do that but it's and and it was
my point when I talked about uh you know
why does why does factions have to be
this huge thing well I understand
because they they they separated it out
as part it's not it's not a part of of
The Last of Us Part Two anymore it's
this own game I understand that it has
to be something bigger I understand that
you have to make it into something that
has that stickiness that you have people
coming back to because of the amount of
money invested into I get that um and I
just think for it it was it was going
too far in that direction and that's not
something she was on board for and
Theory it it just really feels like now
the scary part about that right when you
look at PlayStation and what people
expect of
PlayStation um obviously I would think
it's it's ridiculously stupid to to
Pivot completely away from them games
and hey we're not giving you these type
of games anymore you see the success of
a Spider-Man people's excitement for a
wolverine
excitement for a ghost of sushima sequel
stuff like that and and the next Last of
Us so those things are still going to be
there but I just think I think the
Cadence of those games is going to be
stretched out even more these games may
take you know and jaffy I'm interested
unless Herman Holz has a plan where he
says look wait a minute this is
ridiculous Allan Wake just shipped for
50 million yeah it took him a couple of
years to make yep it's it's a game of
the year Contender for a lot of
people we we can still make the kind of
games we're beloved for but we got to
figure out that's our pivot right maybe
that's what I mean who knows if I was
Herman Hol I'd be going what what what
are they doing there at remedy that we
should try that's the sh Len point I
like hey we can we have to figure out
how to be able to make these games for
less money because the budgets are are
the budgets are out of control the
amount of time we're spending making
them is out of control right so how do
we do that and to your point exactly
remedy Allan Wake proper went into
production whatever four or five years
ago although it's been an idea in the
making for the past 13 years but it is
something that you have to look at and
say hey look at this level of quality so
maybe we don't make Ragnarok a 35h hour
single player game narrative game we
make it a 20h hour game right um and
maybe we have Wolverine taking place in
the same universe as Spider-Man as they
announced they've confirmed they've
confed because maybe we have a third of
the game set in New York that we already
have built um and we'll add stuff and
we'll we'll make it feel fresh but we're
not going to reinvent the wheel
Insomniac it out of all the studios out
there Triple A seems to know the formula
for going we're going to reinvent the
wheel as much as we can but we're also
going to ship on time and we're not
going to kill our teams and so there is
something to be said for that you know
trauma that's occurring in the industry
right now around single player AAA and
going what may emerge from that is
someone crack the nut and says we can
still make viable great single player
big games we've just kind of gone a
little crazy with these like like you
said 70 hour games and all that stuff I
I think this bloat all the way around
and I think that the what's going to
happen is right it this is going to be a
very very bumpy ride because when we
talk about bloat people gonna lose their
jobs if if they come to the correct
decision is how do we figure out how to
debloat this thing and make quality
games within a reasonable amount of time
with reasonable budgets at the end of
the day that means people lose their job
it's going to happen I want to ask go
ahead go ahead yeah I got to ask know he
been patient um you know me and you we
we've been through all the PlayStation
errors right me and you you know you
were the first I never forget that you
know that gray system don't forget about
me I'll Bean you with there
too D I love you I love you but you got
to say king is my source cuz like I was
broke so he gets the Imports right and
I'm like I'm mooching I'm just going to
keep it real I'm mooching
money weing he brings Japanese
PlayStation we like oh my God this is
the most amazing thing I see b n Co
Ridge Racer tack it on the system 11
board I'm Blown Away jumping flash all
these crazy games battle arena to CH I'm
hooked I'm like Sony all day let's go
they killed
Dreamcast like whatever right so my
thing is to me it's like what we known
him for and then we oford to jaffy like
she's part of this like she's the
essence of this right and and continues
on with a lot of their their biggest
games so I I look at that as like
culture what defin you right and then I
remember K you remember like PS3 came
out right and then was a little bit of a
what say a let say culture change but
Attitude Change you know hey we got get
jobi was going swinging little ous right
comei was swinging for the fences box he
was swinging for the fences and the gold
post yeah he he was tearing it up you
have two jobs this facts for the George
Foreman grill one but listen
conversations have been told for us to
have the same thing you know shout out
to Todd Howard let's go so my question
kick is like this maybe I'm overreacting
I don't want to get Doom and Gloom but
it's like these are people who made the
culture of who you are right this is the
essence of why you're successful tell
the truth is this part of like I don't
want to say like the Arrogant heel turn
again like are we are we going because
we're selling so well they're not going
to get off of this one but by but here's
the KY in defense though they are
selling so well so you could be sitting
there and look like look but I'm saying
forget about I know your theory about
the scalers but let's get all I'm saying
is the brass TX says the console is
moving it is successful even though we
seeing all these things and some
potential issues right is it a situation
where you can sit like hey we don't got
to really change cuz look you know they
going to buy it regardless
going do what we want them to so do you
see hu what do you see out of all this I
already told you Rome was bur a long
time ago this is just aied fact of uh
you're going to see it it's it's it's
it's you you're seeing the magnifying
does that mean Rome is burning you mean
he going to break it down he going
remember the Roman Empire the Roman I
know what happened in Rome but how does
it relate to play well well they're Rome
right now they yeah they're Rome right
regardless to what they what they say
moves and needle they have people that
are literally can watch a buggy mess of
a situation and don't report the bugs
because we're not GNA do that like
that's this is Rome we're gonna hold
Rome up to a different standard this is
Rome if you're down with Rome is Rome
right and so Connie is Christ and they
kill her no no wait wait stop
that